though a bill life was actually founded
in 2014 but I started in 2013 and it
took about a year to develop the product
that we have now that's on the market
which is the calibrates plus it's a back
brace specifically designed for
Parkinson's patients to improve posture
and balance one of the avenues by which
students and faculty are really able to
come together and share their thoughts
and opinions and experiences regarding
entrepreneurship is through centers like
Project Olympus and so that's actually
where the beginning stages of my company
started going to project Olympus with
literally one sheet of paper about what
I wanted to build life to be and then
meeting students and faculty from
different seminars that were free and
open to anyone on campus was incredibly
helpful to me Carly melon they work a
lot with Chatham University and there's
an amazing women entrepreneur Center I
was immediately plugged into that that
ecosystem and that's been incredibly
helpful for me as I grow I think that
there are so many entrepreneurs on the
campus and as I started getting more and
more into the entrepreneurial community
I realized how many people who are
involved in entrepreneurial activities
whether it be posting seminars about
fundraising and I mean the right
teammates do students starting their own
companies - faculty actually spinning
out some of their university research
into viable companies and so I really
believe that having that ecosystem there
is so integral to carnegie-mellon
success as
a university that's known for innovation
and entrepreneurship
you